this talk is about how I we create
course materials at university of zurich
and specifically about the tool we are
using for this which we developed over
the last three years so let's start with
one of my favorite quotes about
mathematica Mathematica will
revolutionize the teaching and learning
of math by focusing on the pros of
mathematics without getting lost in a
grammar so this is a quote from a quite
like Visionnaire and Steven and Conrad
use it in their talks and yeah it's back
from 1988 and they're there two ways to
think about this quote I think we all
agree that the Wolfram language has all
liked the built-in knowledge all the
data sources and like all it needs to
make teaching or improve teaching and
learning for students but on the other
side today this quote is more than 20
years old and I don't know about you but
I haven't seen Mathematica during my
studies or in school and so why don't we
see it and I think the answer is for
from builds all these great technologies
but to use all of them in the classroom
on a daily day by day basis on like
teaching job it needs a little bit more
it needs
some like tool or something that puts
all the pieces of Technology together
and yeah so i think that's that's a
reason we don't see the eight much but
it is already in classroom so this is a
picture from zurich january this year
and what you see on this image is a
large classroom with a hundred fifty
students and they are writing an exam
and the guy here and the front can see
it this is carl professor of status in
statistics and operations research the
university of zurich and yeah maybe you
cannot see very well so i have another
picture from this so all the students
are using computers and on all the
computers there is mathematical running
and they're solving exams with
Mathematica and as you can see it here
from screen so there is no paper in this
exam the students will just upload their
files and that is it all right and so we
created the exams and all the courseware
for this course with creo so what is
creo technically speaking Creole is a
pallet and mathematica which is
connected to a package developed by us
and this is connected to a cloud and i
will show you this in a minute
practically speaking for teachers
careers just an add-on to Mathematica
that allows you to create and deep
or any kind of course materials all
right so I said it's a pellet so here
it's in the palette menu alright so it
would ask me for login let's see so
everything I show you is somehow
dependent on the Wi-Fi here which is
obviously not the best so I hope works
so so this is creo it lives in
Mathematica and it comes with user
accounts so this is my account and why
is there why do we need account that is
because all the files all the course
materials are stored in the cloud so we
can work with them conveniently in teams
we can work in the US or in Europe or we
want and so here are some of the courses
and now i will show you an example so
this talk is only 25 minutes so i can
only zoom in a little bit there's not
enough time to show you all of it but i
really want to give you an expression
and yeah so all right little bit because
of the the
yeah so I hope you can see this this
navigation bar in the top so creo is
basically an authoring tool so we open
the file now which is a notebook but it
comes with a specific navigation bar and
the general idea is in order to make it
more convenient we wanted to have
something like what you see is what you
get something like a PowerPoint but with
all the power of Mathematica inside so
yeah so this is an example course and so
I just created it so this for example is
just a lecture so we see all the custom
styles and environments you would use
creating courseware and yeah so this is
the first lecture and here is a preview
of this lecture and just getting started
um yeah I can just use this and write
some more text so yeah we have items and
all this stuff definitions get a little
bit of highlighting we can use warm of
queries
so yeah here's an example you see all
right so that's the brother today and
here's an example so here you see this
is blue this is for typesetting so so
that you can make this look beautiful
and if you say this AE should be 0
mamita so then this gets blue all right
so so far I mean this is basically what
you can do in PowerPoint and in latex
for example so what is what we need
mathematical form so one thing which is
useful is the following so we have
different environments here in increase
oh the working environment you know this
if you have created a slideshow on your
own then we have the preview of the
slideshow so that's just what I created
now and how the notebook for the student
would look then later and then we have
this reader version and see it here it
looks pretty similar but there's the
idea is when we create some course
materials for lecture then this is a
presentation and maybe it contains a
definition
and now you you might want to explain or
give it a bit more to the student to
take home so something like an
explanation but you don't want to see
this on your course or on your slide
show in in class and so we have the
slide show where you would not see this
so just the definition we created and
then we have the reader version where
you would see the explanation for this
so this is making use of the notebook
and cell structure in Mathematica so we
can create cause we're and then decide
on how to use the contents in different
environments alright and now comes the
more interesting things so of course we
use coding and so this is pretty
straightforward so this is still
Mathematica so we can just use copy and
paste an example here directly into the
course materials and then we would see
it here but in some cases you might want
to use maybe plots and so on but you
don't want to show the code to the
students and so if that is what you want
just showing the the plot in this case
then you would
say that this is hidden code so then it
gets red frame it's still there so you
can still change it but in this
slideshow that's the version the
students get here you would only see the
image of the plot and in the in this
other case you can see the whole code
and of course students can use and
manipulate the code in the course
materials directly directly to see how
they work so it's something like in the
document Documentation Center you can
play around with the examples all right
and of course one thing that Wolfram
language is particularly interesting for
is using dynamics and here you can might
notice the demonstrations project so I
can just download it download some code
from the demonstrations project yep I
have this here right take the code paste
it here evaluate it and then I get the
demonstration so here I would say this
is a dynamic graphic this is a
demonstration and I don't want the
students to see the code so make it
hidden code and then lay down a slide
show you they would just see the
demonstration
okay so that is basically what it needs
to create course materials and we use
this a lot and then we can just go click
I want to deploy this as a student
notebook proceed and i would get this so
let's see as I just create and it looks
like the slide show preview but
obviously without the authoring tool and
so this is what the students will get
[Music]
yeah okay the idea is the same for
assignments we use automated grading and
we also give data in the assignment I
show you an example but I cannot go into
too much detail see right
yeah the connection is not dead fast
alright so this is an assignment this is
actually a case study you see here the
toolbar is slightly different we have
questions up questions and so on so but
the idea is still the same here we have
some data which will be attached to the
notebook the students get so that they
can do their own coding and here is our
the questions and we have different
question types and we can use code to
have something like answers as formulas
and we can great code and plots like
expressions and all this what we would
need in an exam okay and here the same
begin just with one click we can deploy
this in Mathematica notebook to students
and there's one more interesting thing
we do individualize all our exams so no
snow to students get to say exactly same
exam and here we can get previewed so
this is just deploy to the bow from
cloud now it probably takes a while okay
so here we see the link Oh
to see the link and open this then here
is the test and it will be automatically
graded so this is just a stupid example
but yeah okay so we are using this and
it works we getting more experienced but
yeah there's still some issues when we
have to deal with files then you also
have to worry about uploading
downloading those files then go from
releases new versions of Mathematica
every quarter so then on some other
computers they wouldn't work or then
students run different versions and yeah
so the question is can we reduce our
technical efforts our efforts for
technical support and maintenance even
more furthermore can we make the course
materials more like integrated so we
want to learn what students are doing
when they fill in the tests and when
they look at the course materials we
want to know where they spend the most
time and we also want to tell them so
you did five mistakes in this test and
so you should review the following the
following materials of the of the course
materials but for all this we would need
something else or we would need
a little bit more than just Mathematica
notebooks and the answer is silver so
yeah you can already see it so you see
this is in the browser so this is online
now students would not need mathematical
licenses to access this and this is an
education platform so where students get
different apps here is the app for
courseware and just that this course
right yeah and what you see here looks
pretty similar like in Creole and in
fact it's deployed from creo so this is
what you see here is a past medical
notebook the interesting thing then is
what do we do with the dynamic object
and so they are automatically deployed
as cloud objects yeah and so that's
that's the idea and we will also use
this for the assignment and all kinds of
assessment so all the questions will be
cloud objects each student gets a
different cloud object to answer the
question and then we can great this
automatically but have the convenience
of integrating all this on one platform
so this is silver and let's go back to
creo you see this here already um this
will push the assignment to to the test
app pine and can show you one more
course materials yeah so we have this a
deployment option also in the course
materials so that's all automated the
whole pipeline here okay
so what's next in terms of creo we will
release soon some extensive style and
user interface improvements so we wanted
like even more integrated you've seen
the assessment notebooks did not look
like really pretty and so we will come
up with some more improvements for this
also working on further question types
to add performance improvements you've
seen this all the files live in a cloud
so this is obviously an issue when
you're in the US or Europe and you want
to access your files all this then we
will improve the handling and grading of
assessment and student management in
general and we will start shipping creo
at the end of this year we already have
like some interested teachers on the
waiting list and the the pushing and
deploying to silver will be available in
2017 okay and if you're interested come
and talk to us okay thank you wait
engine